[Music]
one of the shifts that we've seen in
recent years is that diversity has
become a synonym for equality yes
they're very different things we tend to
look at
um minorities as belonging to
communities
and that class is something that applies
largely to the white population
you can have a Thai Versus Society we've
got to diverse society which is deeply
unequal in a a diverse Elite is still an
elite we live in a world where
politicians activists corporations are
happy to talk about political equality
but don't want to do anything about
economic inequality and the point is
that that affects minorities because
minorities are disproportionately
working class and poor those deep
fundamental questions about the kind of
societies we live in no longer get asked
how do we fix this can we fix this
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
guest today is a writer and broadcaster
who's written very interesting things
particularly about the issue of race his
latest book on the same subject is
called not so black and white from white
supremacy to Identity politics Canon
Malik welcome to trigonometry thank you
thanks for having me it's a real
pleasure it's been a long time coming
we've been Keen to have you on the show
for ages you kept saying oh come on when
I've got my book out come on here you
are before we get into the conversation
which we're both really excited to have
with you uh tell us who are you how are
you where you are what has been the
journey through life that's LED you to
be sitting here talking to us
um if I was to tell you my journey
through life it'll take the whole
program so let me just say I'm a I'm a
mainly a writer these days
and I've come into writing uh out of
social and political activism and much
of my writing is about putting
contemporary social political issues in
a broader frame a broader historical
frame so we we wear tendency to look at
issues as they are at the moment
um and that tells us actually very
little about it because you need to know
not just where you are but how you've
got that
um until you need to tell the backstory
as it were and and my latest book the
one you talked about um not so black and
white does that in relation to race that
it in essentially at the heart of it
it's a paradox of contemporary society
which is that on the one hand most
societies and there's a great abhorrence
of racism
um not that racism has disappeared uh it
sort of disfigures the lives of many but
that there's a at a moral level most
societies
um are a poor racist even racists say
I'm not racist but
um at the same time we are we
continually put people into racial and
ethnic boxes and we Define uh people by
the Box their their needs their
aspirations
um the policies that should apply to
them according to those boxes into which
they've been put and it's as if the more
we are poor racism
the more withdrawn to that kind of
racialization and the book is an attempt
to to to address that by looking at how
we've got to where we are so it's partly
a history of race uh the idea of race
and it's partly a history of the
challenge to racism
um and to a racial categorization
and
mostly it's about the intersection of
those two because it's the intersection
of those two histories that tell us
um uh a lot about uh the Contemporary
world and and where we are how how we've
got to work and why we are where we are
and I would argue there is another
dimension or another Paradox perhaps
which is certainly I came to this
country in 1995 I would argue the
transformation in our attitudes to
minorities of all kinds in that period
of time has been remarkable and and
starting from by global standards quite
a high base already I mean by global
standards Britain was quite a tolerant
Society anyway it's got more tolerant or
welcoming whatever the right word is I'm
not saying it was perfect of course
you had the conversation that we have
about that issue has only seemed to
intensify and pitch and volume and sort
of screaming particularly in the last
six to seven years would you agree with
that
it's certainly Britain has improved um
and become far more relaxed about issues
of race and of immigration
um than it was when I was growing up I
wouldn't say it was particularly
tolerant when I was growing up I mean I
grew up in a very different Britain
where
um racism was visceral and vicious and
where firebombings and stabbings were
were routine
um where you know I I it'd be rare for
me to come back home from school without
being in a having been in a fight
um it was a largely white school I went
to
um
we live in a very different Britain
today
um that it's not a racism has
disappeared but that kind of
in your face vicious racism is
thankfully very rare
um
and yes there is a paradox that
um the the more relaxed Britain is
um the more tolerance it is in relation
to race the more we talk about it
um
and I I think it's in it part it again
is part of what I try and address
um as to the reasons why and it's
actually very little to do with race
itself I mean there's partly to do with
race in the sense that
um
[Music]
that kind of
um in your face racism is is is largely
gone nevertheless those who live today
today's generation the kinds of
um uh issues they face to them is was is
is is material
um and they a lot of them would would
feel that for instance we know that in
the in the in the job market
there is structural racism in this sense
that
um study after study has shown that if
you send out
um uh CVS identical CVS
but with different names in it so one
appears white in the murder Commerce
other appears um Asian uh Muslim
whatever the you get very different
responses to identical CVS if you're if
you're seen to be
um white you're more likely to get uh
interviews more like to get a job
um we've seen the the report on the Met
for instance and the recent report on
the Met
so
um we should not ignore all that of
course um but at the same time I think
the reason that um
that race seems so
it's kind of
um to figure so much in people's lives
or to shape the way we think about the
world there's actually little to do with
race itself
it's to do with the broader decline of
what I'd call the radical Universalist
Tradition now when I again when I was
growing up the um racism was fierce but
the left held on to a a Universalist
position the idea of um equal rights for
all
um that racism was about or anti-racism
was about challenging the um the the the
the
failure to treat people equally
um
over space of just a decade perhaps
through the 80s
um
the left lost much of its uh
Universalist perspective it became much
more drawn towards
um
a particular identitarian viewpoint
and the reason for that is as to do with
the broader context
um of the left
um there's always been identitarian
strains within anti-racist anti-colonial
movements if you go back to the 19th
century at the back to Africa movements
he had gone and visit them in the early
20th century pan-africanism negritude
and so on but these movements were
largely
relatively marginal
that the main
um the main motive of the struggles for
for equality against colonialism Against
Racism
um those struggles were driven by a
Universalist perspective
um and all the great movements that made
the modern world from anti-colonial
movements anti-apartheid movements to
battle for gay rights and so on Battle
for women's rights and so on have all
were driven by that sense of uh uh a a
Universalist perspective
but that
universalism depends on uh rests on on
the idea that on the belief that you can
transform Society
the change is possible
and that belief is ebbed over the past
40 50 years because the the kind of the
the radical social movements have
disintegrated the labor movement is as
as decayed
um
organizations such as trade unions
um uh have lost influence the leftist
Lost influence
um and so people have been drawn more
and more
into
um their own much more narrow identities
as as a kind of Refuge almost
um and the more you you can't you within
that box within that cage of identity
the more the whole world
um can only be seen through those
through that through that box of that or
that cage and so that more and more it
feels as if that's the only way to
understand the world
and it seems to me that the the the the
rise of identitarianism
as I should much less to do with what
people talk about in terms of um
identities or race or much more to do
with the decline of the that broader
sense of possibilities of social change
there's such a profound Point Cannon
because when you looked at 2020 and the
killing of George Floyd and then the
rise to prominence of the BLM movement
and you looked at what they stood for it
was Hardline Marxist agenda abolish
capitalism you know the nuclear family
but etc etc etc and
people who espouse those sort of views
are effectively saying Society isn't
working for me and the only way it can
work for me is if we get rid of
everything and then start again
well
we could have a discussion about black
lives matter and and and what it stood
for
um my critique a bit would be different
from yours
um
but I think that there is a kind of what
what happens is that that kind of
um anti-capitalism that kind of against
the system tends to be more gestural
rhetorical than
um
done their beginning reality to it
because the kinds of movements um that
that once existed that gave those kinds
of rhetoric
um uh reality no longer exist and so it
becomes
um largely rhetorical
and what effect do you think that has on
society that we have gone from this
Universalist position which you
explained so beautifully to where we are
now which is a far more identitarian is
that a positive are there elements of it
that are positive is it largely negative
it's largely negative
um
because it because that sense of social
pessimism I was talking about that I
believe that you can't
um overcome the fishes of race and and
identity that those divisions are are
too great
um
if you believe that then then inevitably
you'll the the meaning of anti-racism
changes
it changes from being
um a movement for material change to a
moving full symbolic representational
change it becomes
um a movement that
um
relies on on making white people feel
guilty
rather than actually bringing back
change for for
um uh minorities going back to this
black lives matter movement my critique
uh I want at the level that that that of
the slogan
um it's an important slogan in the world
would disagreement of course it's not
saying that only black lives matter yeah
but they're in a world in which
um George Floyd was killed and which
there are disproportionate killings of
um uh of of black people in America
um by the police then
um but the idea is the black lives
matter means black lives also matter
um that should matter equally
but the real problem it seems to me with
black lives matter is the is the is that
it confuses the fighting racism
with building racial solidarity and
they're two different things
um
the
the idea of a global black family
is a confected Unity there is no such
thing because
um black communities as much as any
other community are
um broken down fractured by
um class by uh gender all sorts of
things like culture and geographical
origin I mean the afro-caribbean to
African differences sure very Stark yeah
um
and so one of the stories I tell in the
book is about a a strike a sanitation
workers strike in New Orleans
um they want the sanitation workers in
New Orleans and if you know anything
about the history of American
um uh Labor Relations you'll know the
importance of sanitation workers strikes
they kind of play the important part in
in American history and including
American black history and it was a
famous sanitation workers strike in
Memphis and in in in the 1960s
uh which Martin Luther King was visiting
um to give support one of the most
important strikes in the 60s in America
um
it's he was envisaging them when he was
shot when he was assassinated
anyway the the New Orleans strike um
sanitation workers type began in um
early 2020
um and
virtually all the workers were black
um and they they came out in strike
because of poverty wages because of lack
of equipment
um protective equipment during covid and
because of a refusal to be allowed to
unionize
but if all the workers are black
it was also a black-owned company
because as part of his anti-racist Drive
New Orleans had subcontracted out its
sanitation work to a black company a
black-owned company
and what black lives matter
meant
was very different on the two sides of
the picket line
it was very different what black lives
matter meant to
um uh the black workers it's very
different from what black lives matter
meant to Black employers so the the
workers came out on strike about three
weeks I think before George Floyd was
killed that was the summer of
um when when Black lives matter and and
um the idea of racism and the need to
Fight Against Racism became a global
issue
and they were on strike right throughout
that summer
forced back to work that December that
September having one version none of
their demands despite
um racism being at the top of um
people's agenda
so
what does that mean it meant that the
black employers won the Black workers
lost
in other words black lives matter
um cannot be understood in terms simply
in in a kind of global sense because it
depends on where you stand in your in
your classes are you an employer or your
worker are you well paid or are you
badly paid
um
and what what it suggests or what it
shows is that if you create this kind of
false Unity
um of a black community
it helps the the
um uh the black middle class it helps
those within the black communities who
are already privileged but it does very
little for uh uh black people at the
bottom of the pile
um African-Americans are
disproportionately working class
but because
um
are are are
sensitive what of
um what we need to do is defend the
black community as a whole then actually
their um aspirations their needs get
lost and the needs and aspirations of
middle class blacks are the ones that
are catered to so it sounds like your
critique is that as we abandon a more
class and economics based analysis and
move towards a more identitarian one
that leaves out the complexities of how
people live and so actually the poorest
people in the black community in this
case get left behind because no one is
advocating for them because they're poor
they're being advocated for because of
the color of the skin but it's not very
effective at getting them further up or
improvements in their lives is that
broadly what you're saying um to a large
extent yeah I mean one of the shifts
that we've seen in recent years is
the that diversity has become a synonym
for equality yes and they're two they're
very different things I mean people
um talk about diversity
um for very good reasons the the
um there are lots of marginalized groups
that have been kept left out of society
left out of the gains of society
and it is necessary to to to bring them
into
um those gains of society
but
um you can have a diverse Society we've
got to diverse society which is deeply
unequal
um and so by talking about diversity
rather than equality
um or or reducing equality of diversity
what you do is make actually make the
possibilities of equality that much more
difficult because it becomes ignored
um in a a diverse Elite is still an
elite
um and so it's important that that we're
recognize that
um equality is not just about political
equality it's about economic equality
too and we live in a world where people
are
um where politicians activists
corporations are happy to talk about
political equality but don't want to do
anything about economic inequality and
the point is that that affects
minorities because minorities are
disproportionately working class and
poor and therefore if you don't address
that question then you don't address
um the the the actual needs of the
majority of um of black or Asian people
um in Britain or America
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country with
judgment's health by his ability to
wrestle better in London I have since
found out this has very different
meaning we've all had a night that's got
out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Foods sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we used it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great looked great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we heard hugely successful trip it is
very economical and I felt strong enough
to wrestle American bear which we all
know is grotosely weak compared to Great
Russian Bear if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine ag1 is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try edgy one and get five free
agu1 travel packs and a free one-year
supply of vitamin D with your first
purchase go to drink ag1.com
trigonometry that's drink ag1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like me
why are we not talking about the
economics because to me it seems a
completely ridiculous discussion to talk
about something like race and we go you
know you're people of color well people
of color can be anything from Richie
sunac to someone a Pakistani origin
growing up in Bradford in a desperately
poor deprived part of the UK why are we
having such a if I can put it bluntly a
ridiculous conversation
because
um to have a conversation about economic
inequality
um you have to ask some fundamental
questions about the way societies run
about and the nature of markets about
the nature of profit about putting
profits before people's needs you have
to ask those kinds of difficult
questions and and
few people want to ask those questions
and the kinds of
um broader movements but raise those
questions have disappeared
um it's it's what I was talking about
before that that
um the the the the the collapse of
um broader radical social movements of
um uh working-class movements of trade
unions the loss of power trade unions
um have all played a role in it
um
trading is a hugely important that
where trade unions are strong inequality
tends to be much lower
than where trade unions are weak
um inequality in Britain and in America
shot up in the 1980s when trade unions
were smashed
um and they stayed pretty high ever
since there's a there is you know there
is a a relationship between
um the strength of trade unions and um
inequality
um
and so uh the the answer is uh because
the kinds of
those deep fundamental questions about
the kind of societies we live in
um no longer get asked and it's much
easier then to talk about
um uh right at a political level
um that's all equality at an economic
level and Canon I think that may answer
the question I was going to ask you just
let me feed this back to you and tell me
if I'm hearing you correctly
one of the questions I had for you was
where does the pessimism come from given
the progress we've made on race and by
the way I should add I wasn't suggesting
the Britain in the 80s was this Beacon
of cultural universalism at all I mean I
remember I came to school here in 95 and
I remember me being called a packet
right and I'm from Russia so I'm totally
aware of what you're talking about I
certainly wasn't suggesting that it was
you know perfect but by global standards
actually pretty good however
are you suggesting that the pessimism
about which you talk is not the product
of the lack of progress we've made on
race relations it's a product of the
inequality and the lack of progress
we've made on that front and therefore
people feel like well there's nothing we
can really do to change our material
circumstances therefore let's pursue
this uh more representative more
symbolic agenda is that what you're
saying I'm saying that that
um
to believe to have a radical
Universalist perspective to believe in
in in a universalism in any any kind of
um material sense
you have to have belief that it is
possible to transform Society
um
and the mood and the movement well this
is my point right in terms of race right
we have transformed Society yeah so why
are people pessimistic about our ability
to make progress
because we we have got uh a society
societies where we've made progress when
it comes to race but which are still
deeply unequal
where
um the the impact of uh poverty the
impact of
um lack of resources
um bites very deeply
um and the the kinds of movements
organizations politicians
that used to defend
um uh the working class like did to
defend the pool
um have disappeared so the labor party
now says in this country labor party
says we're not going to get rid of the
um uh two child limits on on benefits
even though
um that very weak
um when kistama made that announcement
um there was a report which came out
which showed that the the impact of of
the um two-child limit on on benefits
was to hugely increase poverty among
certain certain sections of the
population
um so
so while it's a good thing that we've
made progress
um
that kind of progress has been for a
very small section of of society
um
um and those who most benefited from the
kinds of progress we've made in race
I've been
um
middle class uh minorities
um working life minorities have
benefited much less from that
um just as working class uh people as a
whole have benefited much less over the
past 30 40 years so it's that
well it's the it's the way that the
politics and the economics have become
separated on our discussion about
political equality it's become separated
from our discussion about
um economic equality or inequality and
that's part of the problem
and the the thing that I find
frustrating about this speaking of
identitarianism and and this
identarianism movement is how reductive
it is so for instance it was talk about
white and then we'll say like for
instance to me you're white my mother's
Latin American a woman of color
you know my grandfather was an Arab my
my grandmother was descended from South
American Native yeah but look at you
yeah exactly mate and I've got the
accent and I've got tattoos so you know
therefore equals racist but the the
thing that I find really frustrating
about it is that it seems to me that it
was a way to demonize the white working
class as well and if I'm going to put it
bluntly
because it was like well you've got
white privilege and I always was like
hang on somebody born in a council
estate in Middlesbrough who is a product
of a single mother well what privilege
do they have they have no privilege and
yet they have somebody who is an ethnic
minority who grew up in a very nice part
of London lecturing this person which to
me I mean it's abhorrent if I'm being
honest yeah again you have to separate
two things one is why has it become the
case
the
um racism has been reduced to the quest
of white privilege
um and secondly what are the
consequences of that
um and if you look at how
why racism has become reduced the quest
of white privilege again you go back to
what I've been talking about
um which is that sense of social
pessimism
take something like critical race theory
that there are lots of different
discussions and critiques of of critical
race Theory some of which are good some
of which are are bad
but one thing that
um
is rarely talked about
in in the think about critical race
theory is that it's the kind of the
broader political social economic
context in which critical race Theory
becomes
um uh significant
one of the key figures
um of critical race Theory someone that
very few people know about but who is
very important in in developing it was a
guy called Derek Bell
was a uh an American
um African-American lawyer
um who has played an important part in
in
um
uh legal circles with within America
um who began
um as a lawyer working for
um uh National Association for or
colored people in America
um challenging segregation in the South
um and working to desegregate schools in
particular in the south
and he became
um largely disenchanted by the lack of
progress in that
and he came to see the
um believe that racism was ineradicable
that it was there it was it was
um there was an equality black people in
America would never win equality
um
and in a sense that was on underlay many
of the arguments of of critical race
theory that that sense of
um of racism being inerraticable now few
people
however influential Derek ballet's few
people are full so fallen down that kind
of pit of existential despair is as
Belle did nevertheless he has been
hugely influential
um figures from
um you know Barack Obama to Michelle
Alexander wine range of figures
and
um
if you take a figure like tanahiti coats
um who you may know about is possibly
the most influential
um uh African-American essayists in in
America
um just most influential essays in
he sees for instance that racism
he Compares racism to a natural disaster
like a typhoon or an earthquake and he
says just this social movements or laws
will never stop
um a typhoon or an earthquake nor will
it ever eradicate racism
and once you you kind of come to believe
that
um then there are a number of
consequences of that first it becomes
you come to see it is see race as
something fixed
and racial divisions as something fixed
um
you essentialize them you kind of say
that they're um and so
um even though that's your starting
point is that race is a social construct
your end point is it it is unmovable
racial divisions are unmovable and you
come to almost the same position as as
those on the right who argue that a race
is is a biological reality and racial
differences our biological realities and
policies should be
um related to that
it also means that going back to what we
were talking before that that
um
the the
struggle against Ray if if you're
struggling Against Racism at the same
time as they believe that racism cannot
be overcome
then you you shift from what we were
talking about before from a view of
material change
to a viewer about symbolic change and
what matters then becomes symbolism and
and anti-racism becomes a kind of uh a
performative Act
um and so a lot of what we're talking
about a lot of
um uh the kind of critique of
anti-racism uh contemporary anti-racism
stems I think
um not from you know malice or or or
um
a desire to to be to be racist you know
all the things that people
um express it comes from that sense of
social pessimism the pessimism about
being able to overcome racism
um and as you say I mean part of part of
the
um part of the irony of that is that
um
um you know if anything the last 40 50
years has shown it is the possibilities
of overcoming racism of
um not that we've overcome racism but
certainly we've ameliorated racism
um to an extent that would have been
unimaginable
um 50 years ago 60 years or 70 years ago
um so
again it comes back to to my point that
that you have to understand this in the
context of The Wider shifts
um in society and and The Wider sense of
social pessimism that there has that
that has
um ripped many sections of society which
in your view comes from the economic
dimension of all of this basically right
and political and political
um it's very interesting political
because if you have for instance
um uh Social Democratic parties
um um in Europe
um Democrats in in in America
um
essentially cutting themselves off from
their working-class base from their old
working class space yeah
um then that becomes a
um uh and refounding themselves or think
largely about
um
uh um middle class support then um
you can see when and that sense of
betrayal and abandonment comes from well
right there's no whatever your skin
color there's no one you can vote for
there's gonna that's gonna challenge
authority on your behalf and represent
your interest in in the conversation
about how resources are distributed and
so on yeah so that makes sense
um the question I wanted to ask you is
how much of this particularly the way we
think about it in the UK
is imported from America because I feel
that many of the conversations that we
have in this country they just don't
seem to map very well onto the history
and culture of this country and the
society that we have here do you think
there's a dimension where we're sort of
living this increasingly unified
informational field and so whenever a
conversation starts in America and BLM
is a good example of this it's sort of
imported wholesale here and is applied
in a very top-down way to a society that
actually is remarkably different to
America
um yes and no I mean yes in the sense
that um you're right that
um the the economic social political
heft of America means that what happens
in America the debates you have in
America
um necessarily apply to uh uh to other
countries or get important other
countries the the most remarkable
expression of that I've seen is that I
remember being in South Africa
uh where there was a black lives matter
March
now anybody who knows South Africa will
know that the policing of black people
in America is in South Africa is far
more vicious far more brutal than
anything that goes on in America means
brutal in America there goes the
Observer column it goes far far more um
you know the shooting dead of of of of
Strikers
um by the police
and yet
the March was not about
um police brutality in South Africa it
was a police brutality in America right
um and that kind of shows that that
there's a tendency when when we think
about it in in in in in in in in
American terms to ignore what is
actually happening in front of our eyes
on the ground where we are
so um yes in that sense I agree with you
but in the broad sense that we've been
talking about that what this and sorry
it's and and this applies to Britain of
course that that the um the character
the the uh of race and racism in Britain
um and the relationship between
different
um uh of racial categories racial groups
are very it's very different in in
Britain than it is in and the nature of
immigration or all sorts of things are
very different in Britain than it is in
America
at the same time going back to what we
were talking about before
um
the importance of what I call social
pessimism in shaping the way we we look
at
um uh race and identity
um is as significant in Britain as it is
in America
um so which which is why yes I agree
with you but also that though that we
need to take the wider frame into
account too yeah it's it's a really
interesting point that you made the I
guess one of the frustrations that I
have is you know for instance we say sex
is a spectrum and that we're not
obviously not going to get into that but
race is a spectrum you know nobody is
completely white you know nobody you
know we we talk there's there's this
conversation right now happening in
America our Latinos white you know Asian
people should we they be discriminated
against when they come when they apply
for universities because you know
there's they're overrepresented
particularly in stem courses and and so
it just seems to me see that we just
tend to think of these people as
homogeneous blobs almost whilst not
actually drilling down and I just wonder
is do you think we're ever going to go
to that point where we where we're ready
to have a more honest and a more
authentic conversation about race or do
you think it's just going to be
dominated by what we see at the moment
well I think the the this the view of um
racial communities as being homogeneous
groups
um has been disastrous
um
because the people that again go back to
our black lives matter discussion the
people it
um
abandons are those at the bottom
um because you tend to don't tend to
tend to see
um
minorities as being single homogeneous
communities
um the most first the most conservative
voices often get
um
I think it's representative of those
communities so um I mean this is most
visible in Britain in in Muslim
communities that that somehow
um
yeah conservative Muslims are seen as
represented and and liberal Muslims are
seen as somehow not authentic not of
that community so I think
um that view of communities is a
minorities is a as forming homogeneous
communities has been disastrous
and we live in a world in which
we tend to look at
um minorities as belonging to
communities
and that class is something that applies
largely to the white population
but but
does this racialize
um the concept of class and so we have
you know the Notions like the white
working class where
the whiteness seemed to matter more than
their class location
um and and again that that is
um really problem really disastrous for
the white working class as it were
um to view uh that there um their
problems in terms of race or ethnicity
and culture rather in terms of class
um is is deeply problematic and
for example in education which is where
I used to work
um the lowest achieving subgroup
in education is white working class boys
yeah I I think education is quite
interesting because if you take another
issue in in schools that of
um School exclusions yeah
um
um this is seen as uh something that
affects particularly uh black pupils
but actually it affects pupils of um
Caribbean descent
those of um uh or a black African
descent are actually far less affected
um and that's because it's a class
difference again
um
until relatively recently most
um uh people from black of black African
descents in this country
um were more middle class than those who
are on Caribbean um descent
and so it's not an issue of
um
simply of of black pupils being excluded
it's a particular
um set of black pupils who tend to be
um more work in class who are excluded
uh and as it so happens
um white working glass boys are also
included not not to the same extent but
but certainly more than
um
uh
pupils of uh African descent black
African descent so um what is a complex
situation well it's a complex picture
then becomes seen in the kind of narrow
rigid
um uh racial terms which doesn't
actually tell you much about what is
happening or what is going on absolutely
and one of the highest achieving
subgroups in education is West African
girls
goes to West African Heritage they're
absolutely crushing it in exams you can
see they're the ones who are going on to
be doctors scientists lawyers Etc
they're doing fantastically well yet
nobody talks about this
and it just seems to me again that
the problem is is when you have a
conversation that is not honest Canon
you're not discussing all facets of the
problem and when you're not discussing
all facets of the problem you're never
going to solve that problem which is my
concern yeah it's it's um it's not a
question of honesty I think it's the
question of the way we've come to view
the world I've you know I I think it's
wrong to see this as somehow people
being dishonest about about it but we've
come to view the world
and view the categories that matter in
certain ways
um and those tell us actually very
little about
um uh the world as it is so again you
know we talk about Asians
but Asians in the American context which
talk about Asians in a British context
um and Asia means slightly different
American viewers an Asian person in this
country someone from the Indian
subcontinent office ancestries from that
yeah yeah but if you look at Social
outcomes or educational outcomes
you find it's very different from those
of Indian background to those of
Bangladeshi and Pakistani backgrounds
and that again has to do a lot to do
with class
um because those have from Indian
background usually come from
um uh majority that come from middle
class families those from Pakistani or
Bangladeshi backgrounds come from
working class or rural families
um and so
um just to to
the categories we use
to think about these issues themselves
obscure many of the problems we face and
again Asian in the American context I
mean we're talking about a huge wide
range of different communities some of
whom are very poor and do very badly in
things like educational attainment some
of whom are much wealthier and do very
well in educational attainment and and
to kind of put all of them into a single
category Asian
and look at
um how Asians are doing in in in in in
different social
um is to misunderstand
um the roots of many of the problems
um that uh that we face I mean
talk American affirmative action
there's a I don't know if you saw those
paper came out last week which looked at
how
um at uh
top colleges I believe and top colleges
in America
um
pupils with the same
SAT score
um but different income levels
um did and what they found not
surprising but but it's quite Stark in
the way it showed it he said with the
same score
for those who are in the top one percent
um are I think twice as likely
to uh be offered a place at a top
university than those who are um uh at
the bottom
um uh income detail
in other words this is affirmative
action for the very rich
um and so those kinds of issues get
missed out when we when we when we when
the categories we use to understand the
world and how it works
um actually don't serve as well at all I
think that's a very good point actually
and I think what Francis meant was that
because we are quite often misled by a
different world view and misinformed
about the right way to look at it we end
up having fake conversations even if no
one is being actively dishonest no one
may people might not be going into it
going well I know the truth but I'm
gonna say this but we are having the
Wrong conversation which I think is what
you're saying as well and actually I
mean if you look at what you're saying
it's the most obvious thing in the world
because there is a reason why people in
society compete for resources they want
to make more money they want to raise
their status and that is because deep
down we all know that the more money you
have the better you and your children
are going to do in life that's just kind
of how it works that's why we we want
more money that's why we want more
resources so you're saying something
very very accurate and obvious and the
late mortise for this entire
conversation Canon has been the need to
address the inequality that we see in
our societies now and we've got about 15
minutes left I'd love to spend it
talking about that with you
um because you are on the left and I
sense that you are quite in favor of
strong intervention in in that uh in in
the market if you like or in the world
in order to address the disparities
between people at the bottom and people
at the top how do we fix this
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests to your questions
access extra content and now the only
place to watch our Roars on catch-up is
on locals are wall shows still go out at
7pm UK time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but
if you want to watch some after this
time then you're gonna need to sign up
to our locals Ross have now become too
spicy to stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's about see you
all on locals
how do we fix this
can we fix this
well I think the the first I mean it's
it's
to have a debate about
um the market of capitalism we don't
need to have a debate
I think the the first thing is that we
live in a world where
um
profit comes before need
so um wherever you look at um issues
where you know when they look at energy
or or whether you look at
um uh education profit comes before need
and and we need to to to reverse that to
to think about people's needs
um so if you're talking about
um
uh
income for instance
one of the big shifts over the past 40
years has been the
um removal of
um or or the
um the the uh the the curtailment
of the rights of trade unions
um it's been made more and more
difficult for trade unions to come out
on strike
um for trade unions to show solidarity
with other trade unions
um to to have
um secondary action all those things
have gone
and if we if we're serious
about
wanting to um
defend those at the bottom if we're
serious about wanting to defend the poor
if we're serious about wanting to
um uh undermine inequalities
then you have to be serious about
opposing those kinds of restrictions on
trade unions because
um if you look right to if you look
throughout the 20th century
those times when tradings were strong
inequality was low
when trade unions are weakened
inequality shoots up there's a there's a
it's not true just a brick you guys you
see the same picture in America
so
um one of one of the things that that
um
that always strikes me is that
um the question of class is now
something that the the people on the
right to take up conservatives take up
so it's an issue
but to me it's as performative
as
um left with much of left-wing
anti-racism
um right-wing
um uh Defensive class because they'll
talk about class
but they won't do any of the things
necessary to defend working-class people
the moment where glass people go out on
strike
um
their argument is that we must do
something to to restrict the the the the
rights of trade unions even more because
they're still going on on strike
so it seems to me that um if we want to
take seriously questions of class for
once like series of questions for
inequality if we want to take seriously
questions of poverty
then one starting point
a lot of um uh starting points but one
starting point has to be
um the the removal of nearly 40 Years of
restrictions on trade unions to defend
their rights
so let me put just push back on that at
this point Kenneth because there'll be
people sitting down watching this going
hang on a minute
1970s the unions were very strong we had
a three-day week the the UK economy was
quite frankly decimated we were known as
the sick man of Europe Thatcher came in
reduced the power of the unions broke
the power of the unions
Britain became a far wealthy and far
more successful country and what happens
inequality
isn't that really the conversation Canon
because
I think
both sides of this discussion always
want to pretend that they have a
solution whereas if you're a neutral and
honest Observer what you see is there a
trade-offs so for example when you talk
about we need to put need above profit I
lived in a society that put need above
profit didn't work out very well right
but that's not to say we should profit
put profit above need in all
circumstances there is a balance between
the two and we must look for the right
place where that balance is whereby we
still have profit and we still generate
enough revenue or stuff or goods for
people to enjoy in society while as I
think you're right to say making sure
that in the pursuit of that we do not
leave people behind because I'm very
persuaded by the evidence on this which
is uh the well-being of a society and
there's a lot of statistical evidence
for this depends not so much on its
absolute income but on the distribution
of that income across society and I
think the concern about inequality is
something that I really share actually
but but the question I was going to put
you slightly different which is
in the 70s yes the unions were largely
dismantled by a political force but
isn't the reason that we don't have
powerful unions now more about the fact
that the industries which lent
themselves to unionization and that sort
of power don't really exist there isn't
a million miners in this country now
there aren't you know that many bus
drivers there aren't that many yeah
there are some but you're not going to
get the working class United around the
stuff because the working class doesn't
really exist in the same way that it did
40 50 years ago there is a large element
of Truth in that but then um
partly it's also because
um
one one one one way of looking at what
you're saying is that word class become
fragmented and that many of those who
work
um the kinds of jobs they have are jobs
which um
in which employees make it very very
difficult to unionize
um the gig economy so if you look at
what's happening with Amazon now or Uber
drivers or whatever yeah
but there is a drive now to to unionize
um Amazon workers
um and to
um
to to uh improve their wages and
conditions
um which anybody who who who who
um defends
um
the the need to improve
um the the the the the
um the the the the conditions the wages
um of of those at the bottom of society
who who wants less inequality has to
support
um just as the other side can we had
James Bloodworth on the show to talk
about his book about conditions uh at
Amazon warehouses so I know what you're
talking about
um but it's not just I'm I mean I mean I
mean that's where the focus is now yes
but there is the
we've got to a point where it's very
difficult to unionize
um
where um it's very difficult to go out
and strike
um
and that kind of collective action
that um that used to be part and parcel
of working class life as God has
disappeared
um and again if if we're talking about
um
defending working-class interests if
we're talking about defending the
interest of the poor then we have to
also defend
um their ability to act collectively
um as a group
um because
um
as individuals
workers are very very little power
um
the only way that they they can express
their power is through to Collective
action and yet it's Collective action
that the you know we live in a world
where we fear Collective action in that
sense
so to defend Collective action to defend
um the idea that
um uh something like the the water
companies shouldn't rip off the public
to defend the idea of a well-resourced
well-funded National Health Service it's
not to us to live in Russia it's to
um to look at the problems we have now
and say that if we want we're serious
about addressing these problems
um then there are certain things we have
to do
and Canon we are it's looking more and
more likely as the conservatives uh
imploding in front of our eyes that
we're going to get a labor government
okay starmer
are you hopeful no
why not because
um
I think it's made it clear
that um
even even minor changes
um to improve the lives of those
um who are poorest
um it's off the agenda
um I mean
we'll wait to see you know if there is a
labor government if there's a labor
government and we'll wait to see you
know what happens then but no I'm not
I'm not particularly hopeful
um that things will change I mean on
everything from
from uh benefits to immigration you know
the the the policies that labor follow
um are not that different from the
policies the the tourists pursue at the
moment it's so interesting because
you're not the first person on the left
that we've had on the show who Francis
has asked that question about the labor
party coming in and answered usually
it's very much the same there's almost
certainly going to be an incoming labor
government Under kirst Armor by the
looks of the politics today as it is are
you excited from your perspective where
you sit on the left about that Prospect
no
what's interesting as well is when we
have people from the right on the show
and we ask them about the conservative
party they feel exactly the same way
about the conservative party so it's
almost like the the labor party doesn't
represent the left and and the
conservative party doesn't represent
what people want on the right which
comes back to your point about social
pessimism because if you can't vote for
a party that actually represents what
you want
why would you be optimistic about the
future sure oh I completely agree yeah
it's a it's a weird place for us to be
in a society
do you think something like proportional
representation would help as in we'll
get more lots of more frag fragmentation
and there'll be lots of smaller parties
which would then the argument is
represent people better if you want the
progressive left you can get for example
the momentum part if you want the old
school lift you get something like the
sdps for example
I don't think that the answer I mean we
can have a debate about
um about proportional representation
um good about it and there are arguments
um I think either way on this but I
don't think the problem is the
mechanisms of of of politics I think
it's it's at a
a more profound level of ideas and of
enough
um organizations that can bring and and
belief and change
um it's at that level that
um the problem lies now and how do you
get people to believe and change if they
can't vote for it
because changes isn't simply about
voting I mean
um
being able to
um organize collectively to bring about
change whether it's in in a in a
um to change one's uh housing conditions
to change one's
um
conditions of work
and to improve one's wages all those
things are part and parcel of bringing
back change I mean democracy isn't
simply about putting a cross on a you
know on a ballot paper every five years
it is about all that happens in between
it is about civil societies about the
organizations of civil societies they're
about it's the ability to be able to
protest is
um it's just the ability to take action
collectively all those things
um are Central
um to a Democratic Society and too often
we we kind of think that democracy is
only about elections and forget about
all the rest and you know at a time when
um there are increasing curbs and
protests
um
I think we we should remember that that
you know authoritarian countries don't
um often don't stop people voting
but they stop people protesting they
stop people being able to express their
views they lock people up for doing that
so it's important to to recognize that
that you know the issues and simply
about voting it is about all the the the
the the the
um tumult of civil society and our
capacity
um to to get together and and um uh to
organize
um uh whether it's a union or a housing
committee or whatever it is it is in
that that the Democracy lies Canada I
think it's a beautiful point to end this
section of the interview on it's been
really refreshing to hear your take on
it the book is not so black and white
we're going to go to your questions on
locals in a second but before we do we
always finish the main interview with
the same question Canon which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that you think we really
should be well
we talk about immigration
obsessively incessantly probably too
much
but despite our obsessive talk
discussions about immigration
we actually have very little
understanding
how the
um the the the the the policies
that are being enacted
um to stem immigration
um um into
um Europe into Britain into America into
Australia and so on how they're changing
the geography of the world
um and what I mean is this you take
something like the EU
over the past 20 years the EU has
um
created a set of
um deals with just about every coercive
force in
um North Africa in the Sahel in East
Africa
um in the whole of Africa
um from malicious to dictators I mean it
began with a deal with Gaddafi when he
was in a power in Libya and he's made a
deal with uh al-Bashir the the the the
former Sudanese leaders wanted for uh
war crimes but in general
um Criminal Court
um
and it's effectively created and it's
made these deals
um with all these coercive forces to
stop migrants from coming to the
Mediterranean
um to cross over to Europe
and what it's really done is created a
huge kidnap and detention industry right
across the region
and in so doing it has
um
trampled over
the rights and the sovereignty of most
many of those countries
um because
um for EU cash they have to put the
interest of um EU migration before they
put the interest of their own peoples or
their own economies is destroyed
economies
um it is um
turned lives of people in places like
Niger upside down uh country most people
haven't probably even thought about
um
and it's not just the EU we can see it's
similar processes in you know in America
or in Australia and Britain
um
of use of using and the irony is that
the
um the argument
um for for for for these policies is
that we need to protect our borders from
from from immigration
but in so doing
what what rich country is doing is
trampling over the sovereignty and
borders of poorer countries
and that's something that we rarely talk
about
um that the way that
um the immigration policies of the rich
countries
um are making poorer countries
subservient to their needs their
immigration needs and um
undermining overturning local economies
and and and the needs of people and I
think that's something it's a scandal
that I think we should
um and the fact that we're not talking
about it is also a scandal well we've
got more questions for you from our
audience head on over to locals guys
where we will follow up uh with more of
your questions for Kenneth
why do the far left and the far right
hold very similar opinions on Israel and
Jews in general
[Music]